thug life sasha alexander bruce chub one
of the most charming grandmasters at
elite level also has a chance to qualify
to play Magnus Carson in the can base in
this video we're gonna look at five of
his most amazing moose do like do
subscribe and let me know which of the
Moose is your favorite on to example
number one in this example a Grizz Chuck
has the white pieces against rubella ski
a very strong Russian player and it
looks like he's in a little bit of
trouble on g2 but he had foreseen a
brilliant idea that gives him a winning
game can you see the same idea what is
it remember to pause if you need to try
to work some of them out for yourself
the idea is rook takes c6 and this move
on its own is maybe not that amazing but
it's the next couple of moves which make
it Sparkle like a diamonds pawn takes c6
and now did you see the follow up this
is where it's important one move is just
one move you need to see the combination
rook takes f7 and this is a unbelievable
way to Queen bury the b-pawn this pawn
is now unstoppable here black tried
roots where for trying to get his rook
behind that passed pawn but now just the
very calm sea free it strikes me that
mr. Fogg life is one of the calmest
elite players around and this move I
feel sums up his personality there's now
no way that black can stop the b-pawn
the comedy Queen some Wroblewski resigns
onto example up to their short and sweet
today just like grit chucks answers in
his press conferences and in this
position his queen is threatened by the
bishop on g7 now a normal human being
would probably think my Queens
threatened shall I made the Queen I
should move my queen but not Griff Chuck
and now he plays a little a little
shuffle move can you see it giving a
little clue of my hand there
just-just-just should do being a rook
rook maybe rook
g1 and this is a beautiful idea which
forces resignation the point of this is
if black takes the Queen rook to g8 is a
very unique and pretty checkmate and
this again shows grid tricks amazing
tactical ability this next example is
taken from chess coms own speeches
challenge
Grichuk with white pieces is playing NBL
another player who's going to be in the
candidates nowadays and I'm very excited
to see how both of these players will do
Chris Chuck is an outside bet I think
he's not a bad outside bet and in this
position white is a rug down as we can
see and the problem black has is the
awful positioning of his King now does
white have to take a draw by repeating
the rook on these two squares given a
little perpetual or can he do better
well as you can probably guess you can
do better because otherwise I probably
won't be doing this video would i but
what move finds the winning idea here h4
a lovely move using a Harry to create a
mating net and pointers Queen to g5 is
now unstoppable and this is a very
beautiful subtle and quite quiet way of
weaving a very pretty position around
the black king for example bishops b7
Queen to g5 and after the Queen comes
off we might as well take with Harry the
edge porn that's why it's called Harry
giving checkmates very nice stuff from
district so are occasionally moves in a
game of chess which kind of just hit you
like a thunderbolt whoa where did that
come from and that's assuming you're not
standing in a field with like an
umbrella or something and this is one
such position Chris Chuck has the white
pieces and his opponent has just put the
rook on b1 doesn't really seem like
there's much going on but the next move
is a very pretty and not so obvious way
to deal with this move that gives white
a very nice advantage can you see the
move rook to b5 and this is a
discombobulated er one of my favourites
that one and it's disco
relating the black pieces and ends up
winning a bit of material or gaining a
very nice attack and it seems strange to
move the rook into the way at the pawn
but if the pawn captures the rook white
can now take on b1 and he has two big
threats Queen takes rook and pawn takes
pawn we should be very strong and after
this move rook to b5 what else can black
do because the rook on b8 some pre the
rook on B ones on play so the game
actually continued rook takes a one but
now after rook takes b8 you can see that
White's rook has become incredibly
powerful and this is shown by a couple
more moves there is a threats or
something like Queen to f5 in some
positions or something similar to this
and after King to f7 Queen to g3 Queen
d7 'if I've now opens up the last piece
to enter in this very strong attack and
after white takes on h7 he now has the
g6 square available and he goes on to
win in not too many moves so a very hard
move to see if we go back up to b5 and
it's one of those moves which only the
top players vision may be able to notice
if you got that you really have done
well we're gonna end with a move that I
hope you all see now sometimes in chess
you just have to go bang bang mate thank
you very much
maybe nowadays I'll shake their hands
what do we do now instead of shaking
hands wave a little bit of you know bump
in the elbows I don't know but a very
nice finish in this game but maybe not
too hard to find grip sugar with the
white pieces and he has some beautiful
bishops how did he finish off this
position Queen takes h7 check and this
is showing the strength of this
beautiful Bishop on b2 striking across
those dark squares or green squares in
this situation and after King takes
Queen this rook now combines perfectly
with the bishop and when the King goes
back route to h8 is yes please thank you
very much wham bam there we go very nice
way to finish
a little beautiful technique there of
checkmate
well there you go Richard five most
amazing moves some beautiful ideas there
I my eyes he has a brilliant chance of
qualifying sand play magnus carlsen for
the world championships a bit of an
outsider but he's a fantastic player do
you think he's got a chance do you like
those moves are there any other mousse
you would have preferred I included I've
loved here your force do remember to
like and subscribe to this video that
means I can make more videos and if you
didn't like the video why did you watch
it this far
now that's a question for you not not
for me ready is it you know think about
it you know you made it a long way
really okay anyway until next time enjoy